joining me today is the original king of
interviewing a friend a mentor a living
legend and a man who loves a good
Brooklyn water bagel Larry King
welcome to the Reuben report know
whenever I hear legend I think one thing
old well every time we've sat down I oh
I feel that I have to say living legend
at the beginning because well are you
are one of the best compliments I ever
thought was Derek Jeter great Yankee now
owner of the Marlins came over to me at
the all-star game some years ago and
said you he said there are a lot of
phony legends you're a true legend
wow that's pretty good yeah that warms
my heart and that's coming from a legend
because that guy knocked out guys the
true baseball attitude did you ever
think that after all your years in radio
in cable news now doing the digital
thing that you'd be sitting in a garage
being interviewed like this going out to
hundreds of thousands and millions of
people let me tell you the truth
whooping this is the pinnacle of my
career if you'da told me 61 years ago
when I started sixty-one years from
today you'll be known around the world
you'll be called an icon a living legend
and at the height of your career you'll
be in a garage with David Rubin it's
come full circle it's killing me Larry
David but what is that what does that
say about just how everything has
changed I mean the only thing sure is
change the only thing constant is change
when I started in radio we had landlines
went through a phone line I did a
starting rear did local television one
year after I started already always did
both always regarded both equally
I always thought of television as radio
with pictures you could be on a radio
now yeah well we released this as an
audio I know but they don't have to see
it
we could imagine any radio stater of the
mind
but I always took that it as just
communicating so I started radio then
did local television
then the national radio and satellites I
was there when satellites were
introduced I never forgot it
I'm in Washington the guest is in LA and
it feels like he's right there
Yeah right there was amazing
settle and I said satellites that's the
end that completes and then Ted Turner
hired me for CNN and I'm seen around the
world we go up 23,000 miles to go next
door and to Moscow try to explain that
to Jefferson doing that and now after 20
songs 26 years at CNN 61 years in the
business I thought I could retire follow
Slim came along so we gotta do something
so the internet or a TV Hulu who knew
fulness yes and when you tell me about
the Internet what bugs me is where the
hell is it where is the Internet people
talk about the Internet and I even
though just have to accept it correct
I'm a product of all these things but
basically David yeah I am doing exactly
what I did sixty-one years ago what this
what we're doing right now is no
different yeah we're being delivered
differently but what we're doing is no
different
what does that say about this the
ability to sit across from somebody look
them in the eye and actually try to
understand the human experience because
I was saying you in the green room right
before there is a massive Renaissance
right now because of podcasts about
long-form conversation the thing that
you've been doing for 60-some idea
that's where it's happening in podcast
yeah it's not happening on television
not even on cable tow they used to call
you know MSNBC CNN and fox news channels
they're not news channels they have
Trump channels ones pro-trump
ones anti-trump ones sometimes hate from
and as pundits yeah it's 24 hours a day
a pundit
they do not cover the news when the
hurricane was hit in Carolina it was in
a box on the corner of the screen while
they were talking about Trump you saw
where the hurricane was that's not news
do you remember seeing a change on that
because you were at CNN do you remember
what year you started I started pushing
will 1985 and left in 2010 yeah do you
remember seeing something changing in
the way Chloe News reported and the way
I saw it when the other side started you
know we owned it for awhile CNN yeah and
then it was MSNBC and then Fox and we
thought they were little invaders Ted
Turner was a genius and off this pants
genius of the seat of the pants he was
driving in a car one day and the guy
said all news all the time he said why
could not work on toes then he puts it
up on the big bird look what he he is
the revolutionary leader of the second
half of the 20th century changes the
world and look what's come tada the
internet dire everywhere you know the
different side there's good and bad to
it if something happened in the world
right now David everyone knows it in a
minute in a minute yeah the world knows
it Wow what do we do with this stand
with technology is always ahead of the
human advance
so when technologies ahead it's how do
we grasp using this it's a great power
you did Steve Jobs when he started Apple
mm-hmm and I'm wondering if he were here
today if he would know what an impact
that's had in the world because I've had
experts tell me that your iPhone will
control your life
it basically is controlling our lives
right now this is now it's a perfect
Segway my friend can you bust out your
phone I do not have what I found because
I don't want to be I was addicted to
tobacco form age 17 to age 53 when I had
a heart attack I know what addiction is
I would wake up in the morning and grab
the cigarette before I put my glasses on
anything
I see people my wife friends with their
cell phones I have dinner with a friend
I'd ever talked to we sit at then and I
mean and he's yeah I think they get fun
cancer so I have old-school a flip phone
see this phone yeah it's a phone put it
to your ear you hear the other side I
don't text I hear people they call me I
call them normal you're the only person
that I actually call you do realize that
I don't call anybody I just take that
why are you why you is see this & purtz
me yeah you as a broadcaster as a
communicator yeah why do you text well I
can see an emergency I'm stuck I'll be
late yeah but come on sometimes speaking
people eat well look you know this is
what I love to do but sometimes just for
the sake of ease of just you know I'm
gonna be here then or I'll see you there
you know a lot of that I try not to have
long-form discussions about political
news or but yeah people are fighting
over personal things on there and all of
that but wait I want I want to back up
this thing you said before because so
when the satellites started and then you
suddenly were doing interviews with
people where you weren't in the same
room do you remember that affecting the
interviewee because I always like this I
don't know if nothing like other nothing
beats this yeah nothing however I always
try to treat it as this they just
weren't there so I try to make eye
contact via the satellite I try to treat
it as if they were there and what I got
used to handling well and enjoyed was
when I'd have five different guests in
five different places yeah and
controlling that yeah and then I did
diplomacy I had a night where we had
Arafat Rob Dean and king - the king of
Jordan yeah
now I bet his father okay
all three Kissinger told me you're doing
diplomacy yeah I had arafat king of
Jordan and the Prime Minister of Israel
together me a little Jewish kid from
Brooklyn sitting there by satellite but
I felt I was with them yeah I I didn't
treat it as them being there I treat it
as like this
yeah did you in in some of the bigger
interviews that you did over the years I
mean you've interviewed you've truly
interviewed everybody is there anyone
that you felt like you didn't you didn't
get to Castro I went down to Cuba in 19
in 2009 200 9 I was treated regally they
all wonderful to me but I couldn't nail
it I couldn't get him to do I was
fascinated by him because he led his
country longer than any leader in memory
hmm somebody had a local right even if
it was only one person and then when I
went to Havana I never saw a happier
country I was amazed the people smiling
musical hotels mobbed you know from the
Canadians and Germans and beautiful
weather a beautiful city water Havana
ought to be open to everybody it's
beautiful the waters are gorgeous it's a
great city however where were you when
you're interviewing Big Tymers the real
movers and shakers that the ravines and
Arafat's that you mentioned that
something that you asked them could
actually turn the course of history you
know I'm not a well I know a lot of it
did I know the Pearl Gore debate changed
after we Clinton called me up the next
day and said you pass and after yeah
that was way behind until the gold or
Pearl debate you try not to realize it
but once once the light goes on that's
just the moment on in noise high if I'm
sitting with Jimmy Carter or a ballet
dancer once the light goes on I'm in
that moment I don't think about
yesterday can't do anything about it
don't think about tomorrow
tomorrow so I'm in the now so bright in
this now you should be in this now so if
you've got Trump coming tomorrow and
you're thinking about that then you're
losing this moment I'm here I always
treat and I'm here I focused do you
think that your curiosity do you think
you sort of made that for yourself or
was it built into you because I've been
out with you to lunch or dinner
breakfast whatever it is and I can see
you're as curious about the waiter
busboy or sometimes when we were at aura
together and you'd be chatting with you
know the guy doing the lights or
whatever that you were actually as
interested in them as if they was that
and always have that David IgE I
remember as a kid getting on a bus kid
and asking the bus driver why do you
want to drive a bus I remember we go to
ball games hidden Brooklyn go to Dodger
games go with my friends we'd wait
outside for the players they wanted
autographs I never want them to
autograph wanted ask questions I would
run along with a player going to his car
why did why did you bunt why did you do
that I was always a wide person yeah I'm
the kind of person you don't want to sit
next to on an airplane I I'm in sand I
don't know where that came from
but it's the best gift I got was
securely out the gift of curiosity
Anthony Quinn told me that you have the
greatest gift ever curiosity my friend
I'd be calling a roll you can negotiate
anything says to me the secret of my
success is being stupid you doesn't mean
that demeaning basically what you're
doing is saying help me help me with
this why did you do that someone asked
me if you were interviewed Osama bin
Laden
Oh your first question had been well it
would not have been why did you bomb the
World Trade Center it would have been
you grew up in one of the richest
families in Saudi Arabia why'd you leave
now he probably hadn't thought of that
since he left yeah but it forces you to
think and then I'm gonna learn more
about him before I learn about the
bombing and also you have to understand
that nobody nobody thinks they're evil
Hitler did not comb his hair in the
morning and say I am a bad person they
may be crazy but they believe nobody
thinks for I'm really terrible and
everyone has an excuse for what they do
the bank robber that Bank boy my father
they charge his checking account to
screw them yeah and the public funny
enough admirers
the renegade Dillinger was very popular
in America very popular he robbed from
banks who likes banks right so how do
you then interview a bad dude someone
that's got you here you're curious about
a bad dude yeah I not - it's hard
sometimes racists especially yeah I had
a tough time doing the early George
Wallace the later George Wallace was
terrific the early George was not a
tough time because I don't understand
racism I've never understood it yeah I
don't have no understanding of why
someone with a different pigment that's
all it is should be treated differently
you think that comes from just growing
up in Brooklyn in arrogance when it was
such a mess can you just talk about that
a little bit like what that was like
rode up oh I grew up in a neighborhood
of mixed you know we Jews Protestants
Catholics that's it with some blocks not
a lot the blacks went to school with us
when I went down to Miami to break into
radio I was 23 and I got off the train
and the first thing I saw with two water
fountains colored white I drank out of
the college yeah I never seen anything
like that you wrote in Brooklyn that was
beyond me then I got on a bus to go over
Miami Beach to stay with my uncle and
the bus driver stops the bus and
we to move forward because the back is
for blacks and I said to him my father's
black I'll stay in the back so I know I
never understood it I've asked this a
racist I have never understood why a
white feels superior to a black Lenny
Bruce who was a great friend of mine
used to tell me that the human being has
to have something they hate that drives
him because they have an inferiority
complex
so they have to feel superior with
something and he told me four years ago
some day blacks will get equal rights
and we'll have to hate something I'll
tell you what will hate Eskimos
there's always another right in other
words you know you used to check in a
hotel and underneath the chair would be
a sign will move under penalty of law
you know who removes them Eskimos you
know any Eskimo war heroes yeah you
don't know name one I'm gonna Google
that an Eskimo doctor right they were
just trying to find some and racism
always befuddle i interviewed dean rusk
Secretary of State Kennedy years and he
was a very progressive southerner from
Georgia his daughter married a black man
he has he said I have no prejudice Dimas
they taught me a little about pressures
so did not the next Dean Rusk said to me
my daughter married a black man I have
black grandchildren I have no practice I
got on a commercial plane the pilot was
black
and for a minute I was nervous that
shows you how inbred it can be yeah can
he fly the plane but I've never it
boggles me when over the years when
you've talked to some of these people
you know a white supremacist or just
some of these people that come from that
truly racist place did you ever hear
them say anything was it almost like
therapy in a way that you felt if you
talked to them long enough maybe they
could get out of it
ever since why do you try you to try the
best you can now there's some books out
by former white supremacist yeah come
full circle of course they're raised a
lot to do with raising is the major
inferiority complex you got a deal with
that although someone says it's not a
complex they're inferior who were some
of the people that you interviewed that
that you think either it went the wrong
way or any regrets and never sitting
down with someone to go oh man I missed
that more I could tell you one it's the
one try remembers name now it's the guy
who succeeded Steve Jobs they want
immediate well Tim Cook now but it's not
a decision [ __ ] yeah Steve Jobs hired
him no what was his name
bright guy came from PepsiCo low I think
I'll have my guys google it well then he
ran he ran and I had him on for two
hours
yeah great guest now why was it wisely
out what was known why is he a question
this is partner okay well this guy will
play joined the corporation Steve left
out and came back later
okay well we'll grant it so I spend two
hours interviewing this guy who's great
all about it previous jobs and and then
I finish and now I go to calls I used to
do this on my old lady Oh show to our
interviewer Lauer calls in an open phone
America I go to close the first call
Larry Steve Jobs fired him he will place
Steve Jobs and then Steve Jobs fired him
you didn't even ask about that shoulda
known yeah it stopped when one gets by
you right and it haunts you look at out
those years ago is still haunting you
try to know everything you can't there's
no perfect interview you can't know
everything you do the best she can I had
a tough time with Ahmadinejad of Iran
because he would I remember he was
talking me on Scully I think it does it
John Sculley see we've got a crack team
oh yeah you got he's still around
motherly
when I interviewed Ahmadinejad and we're
talking about various things and we're
talking about the Holocaust and he says
to me that's why I always have to listen
when you're doing an interview he said
if there was a Holocaust
why isn't Israel in Poland that's where
the crime have hurt why is the State of
Israel 2,000 miles away there was no
crime in Palestine the crime was in
Poland to Germany why didn't they take
that area and give it to Israel right it
made some sense you could argue with
logically yeah I said to him did you say
if there was a Holocaust and we went
right yes right there
are you saying if you know where we got
contentious you did know it was those
are interesting but look I've had so
many years doing this Dave and I can't
explain how I still love it I love the
interplay yeah
you should love what you do yeah not you
know why you learn something every day
every day you learn so I can't be
closed-minded like I'm a liberal
politically certainly in social issues
but I'm not close-minded enough to think
that you can't have an opposing view I
like the argument I like the discussion
but in interviewing I never I leave my
ego at the door I try not to use the
word I it's irrelevant and I tried to
get in to walk any other you know Edward
Bennett Williams the great lawyer told
me once I said what is the role of the
criminal defense lawyer he said to get
one person on the jury to walk in your
clients shoes if you can get one person
to walking in clients Jews got a hung
jury all he has to do is say I would
have done that
yeah when you were doing five nights a
week and on any gear I used this example
a lot because people will say Oh Dave
you had this you know this bad person on
or this that the other thing I'll say
you know in Larry King's heyday let's go
1990 to CNN you'd have the cast of
friends on Monday you'd have a no Jay
Simpson lawyer on Tuesday you'd have you
know an animal guy on Wednesday you'd
have you know a doctor on on Thursday
and then you know former Secretary of
State on Friday was that crazy for you
know you just loved the bounce or
thought about curiosity most of the
times most of the times driving in I
didn't know I had on that night really I
still don't know Laura I Drive in I
don't know who's on unless it were
really someone famous yeah like we might
have the animal guy I didn't know it
well until I walked in to see all the
animals and because my curiosity comes
from pure curiosity so were your guys
handing you notes right no I get a blue
card like a little I had a blue card we
have facts yeah he was secretary of
state from this year to that year he was
responsible for the Marshall Plan right
that's all and then I would do the
things that how the Marshall Plan come
about yeah how what part of it did you
play with George Marshall misses plan
were you in on the thinking you know
it's all when when we had the Gulf War I
would see other shows in which the
guests would come on be a general
awesome and the host would say today in
the Gulf War 1000 people were killed and
the thing and now the terrain is here
and all I would say is what happened
what happened today because he has the
perspective if you have an interview
where you turn the TV on and the host is
on more than a guest something's wrong
if you if it takes you three sentences
to ask a question something's wrong
because a lot of them are show offs I'll
give you the show off interviewer
regular
my yesterday is Dave Rubin he's written
a new book called Chicago my hometown
it's great to have you here Dave you
know I visited Chicago many times what
was love going there did you or deed do
you write about the the stockyard you
know
stargazer fashion if you ever go there
folks you know in other words you are a
prop for me and that's gone now there
aren't even low shows anymore yeah what
do you make of so when you left CNN I've
said this to you before you left me 2010
it seems to me you can do a pretty clean
line between you leaving sienna and
obviously the Piers Morgan thing didn't
work out if you want to comment on that
you can but that you were one of the
people that people trusted there's
almost no one in news or on television
anymore that people go oh like no one
was walking around well even the people
that maybe didn't like you that much
they were going Larry King's a bad dude
Larry King is a liar you know I mean
nobody was doing that no and then by
having one of the main faces who had
been there for so long I really think it
broke something in the continuity of CNN
that kind of led us to where we are now
related to all cableman maybe maybe it
did there were signs you know Fox News
was beating us we had one at all those
years and Fox News was beating is
beating CNN the day beating us at night
that was a sign this was a network
that's not news but am I making this up
when you left CNN you still have the
highest rated show on the second highest
we started a fall not precipitously but
we started a fall we thought we saw CNN
sword famine forces so do you know CNN
always made a ton of money just they
were the first and everybody in America
at CNN paid 50 cents a month so Ted
Turner that in our lead genius think of
this right now you and I a pain for CNN
we're not watching it you don't pay for
CBS you're paying for CNN
he knew it so CNN made money if they had
no commercials didn't do it just beyond
public tune in
it's a different world now I can't I
don't know maybe it was the cleavage you
know Jerry Seinfeld said my old column I
used to do in USA Today when I did it's
my two cents yeah that was the beginning
of Twitter yeah
really like quick comments but I you
know people call me a pioneer so I know
all I see myself is I'm a lucky Jewish
kid from Brooklyn who was curious and
took that curiosity into a career yeah
and as I was able to take the natural
curiosity and make a career of it
you think we're may be running out of
that when you when you talk to young
people you have to be very young sons
when you talk to young people watch how
they get the news you were telling me
about kids with the phones and
everything and you you love the
newspaper right you are my New York
Times like I got an iPhone
it gave me an iPhone so I use it to get
baseball scores yeah that's all I don't
know I don't have it with me yeah I
don't need it the games are tonight you
go right you're mean you're a major
still a Dodger fan oh yeah I love the
game I though I go to basketball I love
the game I love competition your
gradient at Dodger Stadium right now I
tell you why I love sports sports is the
one is if you're not a sports fan oh
yeah oh yeah okay the best thing about
being a sports fan is it's the one thing
in your life when you get up in the
morning you know who's gonna win so you
have something to look forward to good
or bad you don't know who's gonna win
nobody wakes up to that except sports
fans another thing what I love about
athletes maybe more than any profession
their career is over and other careers a
beginning they have that day when the
cheering stops and you want that's like
yeah you build yourself up in your 37
years old they paid you all this money
for doing what you did as a kid and
another thing the athlete has that we
don't have
final score can't argue that's it eight
to seven you lost you got seven they got
eight you can say yeah but they should
stop you got seven they got it now if
you got eight you get the applause get
them down you get that every day
recognition non-recognition walk down
the street athletes so I love either so
I love all it brings all my curiosity
sports bring into a head because I'm
always interested in last night the
Dodgers loss he left a left-hander in to
pitch that his right-handed bat he's got
all those pitches in the dugout why
he'll even it why did he leave a minute
did you find there was something unique
about the top of the line athletes that
you would talk to that they that they
genuinely had something different no
they had confidence yeah that's it
Stan Musial the great Cardinal
outfielder Wally Westlake was a teammate
of his and he while he told me this
story it's they're sitting in a dugout
before a game and Westlake goes over the
Musial and says Stan I got up this
morning breakfast was great the shower
was great the drive-in was great and in
batting practice I've hit five home runs
I feel great you ever had that kind of
day slam and he said every day the
quarterback who throws ten incomplete
passes never thinks about the eleventh
row to have the ten incomplete effective
confidence they have that ability you
take wide receivers in football they're
all fast they all have good hands it's
the great one the great ones they
believe it's coming Gretzky told me he
saw the puck go into the goal before it
went into the corner it's a so I have
great appreciation I also have
appreciation for politicians they do
something we don't do
they have a first Tuesday in November
they don't have that day they don't have
a first Tuesday in November they win and
lose they stand up before the public and
they win and lose they get rejected
Jimmy Carter telling me the saddest day
of his life was flying home from his
last appearance when his advisors told
him you know they know in the afternoon
yeah you're gonna lose the great story
of Barbara Bush told me when George Bush
lost to Bill Clinton at 3 o'clock me
afternoon they knew he was gonna lose
and they're all sitting around Samba and
Barbara Bush came in and said where do
we get a driver's license all right
first off King we just did something
that we've never done on this what is we
stopped for a moment so that Alexis
could bring you a chocolate shake
normally normally someone with diabetes
and hard finish do not have a chocolate
eclair however I've lost weight and I
don't know why they say it comes with
aging I have I'll try to have a daily
milkshake to not lose any more yeah
that's a that's a little call back to
Brooklyn right oh yeah we had Moulton's
to where they put malt in yeah the candy
store there's no candy stores anymore
there's no case well now they've got
like you know Beverly Hills Super Deluxe
butter canned no I get that candy yeah
put a jukebox and you sit in you have
that greens yeah well let's talk a
little bit about age I guess it's a
little weird to talk about at some level
you are 84 I'll be 85 in November okay
so you can't believe it my father died
at 46 I've had every known disease I
can't believe it I can't believe on this
age what is it what does it feel like
I mean you you've had a couple of heart
attacks of these the diabetes a couple
of things and you're still here you're
doing your thing you're out and about
every morning I bump into you half the
time I think that is the reason I'm
around is that I have a purpose
I am amazed that people who retire as
Milton Berle told me once when I asked
somebody gonna retire and he said to
what what would I do if I get up in the
morning had nothing to do that's
terrible
so I have a place to go to follow my
profession that's wonderful if you can
keep that going I'll probably die on the
air Oh someone else what would you like
you really want to increase my youtube
views right now came from yeah what
would you like your obituary to read and
I said oldest man who ever lived
passed away today in his sleep with a
smile on his face but you still get a
kick out of everything I know it so just
real quick tell tell everybody a little
bit about you have these breakfasts with
your old crew well some of them have
passed away the guys are welcome but we
have a crew of about five or six we meet
every day at different places and we are
tater to David we solve the problems of
the world today we solve the rack hey
audience
no worries about Iraq the table solved
it mostly through jokes we do our jokes
and we talk about people get in
arguments we talk about Israel we talk
about
hearings who's this what's the senator
doing what's he doing and then we also
discussed Sinatra and old-time musicians
and who's doing what and what in barbra
streisand make our last tour and so we
never know where the discussion is going
and that's the wonderful hymn and when
you were gonna have friends from
childhood so a miner passed away but I
still have two others the best thing
about it is I'm not Larry King I'm Larry
cycle that was my birth name and they're
very happy for me but I'm still a
button your button on your shirt you
know I mean they don't treat you like
anything different what's it like as
somebody of a certain age now where you
know you just mentioned you've lost some
childhood friends your brother passed
away just last year so months ago yeah
just watching life turn in that way
that's the saddest Sinatra told me once
the saddest thing about aging is your
friends go before you I didn't want my
brother to die before me he was your
younger brother you know he was a B I'm
yeah he was 80 yeah loss is hard it's
cuz I don't believe in afterlife I'm not
religious you think this is it baby
that's it I have never I've interviewed
thousands of people people who said
they've seen death and all this
I don't buy it I may be a little I don't
buy it
I just it just makes no sense to me that
Lincoln is up there or that there's
someone up there looking down on me I
went to my grandchildren's their twins a
boy and a girl so they had a bot and a
Bar Mitzvah and for the first time in
ages I read from the Old Testament that
God he's a worker son of a [ __ ] Jesus
did he hate it what my enemies rule out
show me one good penny my god believe in
me above me he was vain in credit he was
a Donald Trump before there was a Donald
Trump believe in me above all of us I am
the I can't believe so when I read that
Michael Mele so I can't buy it I've
interviewed all the great religious
leaders except Pope yeah I've never been
convinced so when you when you've sat
down I mean you've sat down with
everybody from the Dalai Lama across the
board with Bree Graham was a friend yeah
so when you've sat down with him even if
you don't believe it did you feel that
some of them were able to get something
out of belief
I believe they believe yeah unless there
are some phonies you know send in $10
and I'll send
a little cross yeah don't buy any of
that no he's that down with some of
those guys do Oh Gerry Falls as George
Burns once said when he played God it's
a great movie great and he gathers all
the religious leaders and he calls in a
Jerry Falwell type and they've all
taught Cosi called me in first goes up
to his room sits down and God says to
him why is she so shoes so I never I
never bought that part but I like Billy
Graham respected him Billy Graham
thought I was very spiritual and do I
believe Billy is with Jesus no no but
Billy believed he believed he was going
to Jesus he had not then have feared
death he had a fear of being in a plane
that's going down the crash but he
didn't fear death I feared I do item
unlike Woody Allen I don't fear it I
just don't want to be there
I can't bless my wife believes I respect
believers see when I approached an
interview with Billy Graham I respect
him I asked him the best questions I
could ask like why do you need to stay
at the Fontainebleau or Isley I've
quoted Lenny Bruce Timm any person who's
got a calling from the Lord to lead the
flock who has more than one suit while
someone has no clothes is a cop-out and
Billy Graham said in today's world you
have to have more than one soon you have
to travel I I asked him if Christ right
Jesus probably had one pair of lip balm
the crease would work what Christ would
he buy suits and he said yes and he
would go on television that was the
means of communication I mean that's
their answer if he believed it I
respected his belief but I'm not afraid
to ask him any question if when you die
if you believe in Jesus Christ you will
live forever what happens to Jews
and he said well I I don't go into them
but maybe at the moment of their death
they accept Christ that's kind of a
cop-out right there's always sort of
another answer
I think did you ever talk to anybody
either religious or otherwise that you
felt had some sort of special insight
into something well I have this doctor
on who was convinced that he had died
visited what the world of afterlife was
and then his life for Savior he was a
recognized doctor you know what disease
he had
I threw it up to a vivid imagination and
he got a best-selling book out of it
people want to believe you know I wished
that I had faith that I could make it's
called a leap of faith though he can't
prove it so it's a leap of faith now we
have faith in a lot of things you get on
an airplane you have the faith that that
airplane company hired a licensed pilot
I but you have some core of belief that
you think if you jump out of the 10th
floor of a building you're not gonna
make it so you don't jump the people who
have that faith who go beyond I just
think they've got a great crutch a great
clutch to know you're going somewhere
and yeah but at the end do you think it
matters if they if they live a good life
and you live a good life first of all
they're never gonna know yeah if they go
somewhere they were right if they don't
they don't know cuz they're dead yeah so
they got a good deal going they really
have a good deal I don't have a Bobby if
I've got an F though I'll be shocked
yeah
but you'll be doing this oh absolutely
or maybe you'll be playing baseball up
there I'm not that good you know that
good let's talk a little bit about
politics
you mentioned Trump we did about 40
minutes his name didn't even come up
once first time in American conversation
82 people had a conversation for 40
minutes in the name Trump they're not
that's one thing he's done I'll bet you
everyone in America at one time today
said the name Trump
everybody everybody is there anyone else
that in the years that you've been doing
this that you saw just that effect he's
the only president that I've known for
40 years I met the other presidents some
before they became President Barack
Obama George Bush Bill Clinton but they
were in the political sphere but Trump
is the only one there was my friend
before you Trump and I went to the Super
Bowl together yeah can you talk about
Medaille with fathers of the year
together
there are 1995 yet his kids and my kids
is all of her story we got trophies I
went to see Marla maples
in her Broadway show I went with Trump I
stated his hotels when I had some minor
surgery in New York he took my wife out
to dinner the night before he caught me
at every hotel he owned put me in a
suite at the Plaza when he owned the
plaza but one thing we always knew about
Trump he was a character and he lied now
he he almost lined by it's snowing out
when it wasn't you know he'd be on my
show and say highest rating it and it
was all about him but he was a character
and it was fun yeah and he could be very
nice and generous okay not all those
qualities but he was a character I mean
he would call up the New York Post with
a different name and tell him stories
about Donald Trump so he can get on page
six that was his goal but President
pressure
are you kidding anybody any of us who
knew him years ago
first he was a moderate it's a central
Democrat supported Hillary Clinton loved
Hillary Clinton thought she was a great
senator he wanted single-payer health
care he didn't care about abortion come
on
evangelicals I don't think Donald ever
read a book but he's but he was a
friendly character to be around a
wonderful guest a lot of fun fly off the
top but President President so what do
you make about what happened here like I
have no idea
Hilary was a bad candidate a wonderful
person I know Hilary very well great
sense of humor
sad I don't know what if she didn't go
to Wisconsin did you get a different
Hilary when you went into her interview
her publicly this is what a lot of her
is is that she's very friendly and open
one-on-one she's good yeah front of an
audience she's not she's not a good if
she's running for something now I went
to Yom Kippur service where she was the
speaker she was terrific she wasn't
running for anything she was a senator
from New York damn good senator she ran
a horrendous campaign and she was not a
good campaign I thought she won the
debates but it almost didn't matter
Trump became well Trump got elected with
that first question in the first
Republican debate when he was asked
about women and did he ever called women
pigs that he said only Rosie O'Donnell
and he sat in the middle of all the
Republicans why did they seat him in the
middle
he was just four on one side for Nia did
you really think it then from that
moment that I thought he would ignite
something but I thought he was dead when
he said that thing about McCain isn't a
hero
certainly when he got off the bus with
Billy Bush I thought that was over
but his base doesn't care if
evangelicals can put aside his personal
life he'll never lose them he'll never
say it's all I ever lived in weird at
times I mean this is the weirdest time
to know every day yeah there's a story
does this truly enjoy yours does this
right now feel like a truly truly unique
time because people ask me that all the
club events I do and I think the answer
is yes although you always think it when
you're living it but of course
irrespective do you believe that
somebody said one day to see what link
understand yesterday what to hear what
Roseville did last night did you see the
speech the Quartermaine through you win
was that weird no they didn't do weird
things
they were president
yeah I remember I was in the White House
interviewing George Bush and Barbara
Bush said to me Larry suspenders in the
White House if she was at the White
House is this place is now I wonder what
it's like in there Tiger the guy writes
the op-ed piece in The New York Times my
god
the wood wood book fascinating book
we're living in those times yeah
wouldn't believe it but I can see as you
talk about it there's a glimmer in your
eye
like there's something exciting about
this do you think that that's in a weird
way the good part of this even if it's
kind of helter skelter now and I'm glad
I'm not on CNN now I wouldn't want to be
doing panels every day and Trump all the
time I don't want to do it yeah that's
not the whole world Trump's not the
whole world he thinks he's the ho ho how
important do you think politics actually
is because I think now there's maybe
what I'm realizing now is that this is
really about culture what we're fighting
right now this this battle that seems to
be in fights about culture it's about
what do we really care about what do we
like not just about the ins and outs and
machinations of you know I think too
much of America is still prejudiced
against Latinos blacks that still runs
through a lot of us in my opinion people
voting against their own self-interest
you know let's I want to face it with
something Obamacare is working for a lot
of people you don't hear many complaints
about people who are under it and
getting good medical care I'm not sure
that I'll ever do away with it no it's
just those those kind of facts are so it
bothers me when I see that why we still
have prejudice in America and appeal to
it I mean Trump even his defendant would
say he appeals to it what do we need a
we need a wall do you think do you think
that's a play by him I mean for all the
years you knew him did you think he was
racist or that this is I never thought
he was racist I think he was opportunity
he was
he took advantage of a situation so we
used to say he wasn't smart
he wasn't book smart I bet it at school
he got a gentleman see the big
influences in his life were Roy Cohn who
I knew very well and his father and they
were bad influences
I mean rogue or homeless I liked him
causing this peculiar yeah but he was
waiting for the people that don't know
who rikon is he was a bad guy he was
part of the McCarthy era and Jana Angels
in America had he played a part in that
play and he was affected by that so I
never I never thought it was a racist
but his narcissism was beyond belief
I in every other sentence I did this I
did that I'm the greatest president he's
ever had
oh he just said it
how could you say that so if you were
sitting down with him I would say Donald
why I spoke to him every day during the
camp but not every day once a week
during the campaign he knew I was voting
for Hillary but we were friends and he
would call me what do you think it is
I'm doing is what do you think of that I
got this where you think it is something
I'm gonna do an interview with the New
York Times you know the guy should I do
this and then when he was elected I
never heard from him again
I would heard do you think we can get
out of this polarization that we seem to
be in so if we're in this unique time
right now in crazy time how's it gonna
change you know we don't have a
forcefully - it might be Bloomberg to
lead us we need someone to lead us all
we need Gary Cooper maybe George Clooney
in the modern society I'm not kidding
George Clooney
bright and he is bright George Clooney
will be very popular women's vote smart
as a whip
what does that tell you though if we
need to go to celebrities you think
maybe we're just in there in this
relative lose this is that's the
internet that's the world we live in
yeah yeah I like George oh ah I'd vote
for ya do you think we can get out of
this well they say America always comes
through everything George will who's
become very anti Trump believes we can
find a way again America as a way of
finding a way I hope so I hope I'm
around to see it but right now you know
one R in my earlier I could name every
senator sending you ten twenty years ago
every son yeah and Ghana Orrin Hatch and
Ted Kennedy were great friends sponsored
bills together hats did his eulogy
mmm-hmm that that wouldn't exist today
that would today the the thing is so bad
when Obama nominated his guy for the
Supreme Court I shouldn't forget his
name and they never brought it up not
course it make we'll get it we'll get it
not one that one when we nominate people
like that who was pretty much middle of
the road Oh
garland America Merrick garland yeah if
I were to Democrats now and they take
the Senate I would hold off any
appointment yeah until they can have a
president and first person our point
would be married column who deserved to
be on that Court yeah so this is just
both of them playing politics to dance
but will we have a chance I I don't see
it coming
you know when Merrick garland was
nominated for excel Orrin Hatch before
he knew they would delay it said he's a
great man hmm and then it becomes
party over country party over country
said well you think it's gonna change I
think that the outrage machine that
we're running on right now I think it
can only last for so long so I think it
couldn't you know either blow up into
something much worse and I don't even
know what I mean by that but I think
things would actually get much worse and
some of this would actually spill over
into violence or what my hope is and I
think this is the more realistic option
is that the outrage will start running
out of steam like a car running out of
gas and that from that somebody whether
maybe it's your Cloney or it's whoever
else it is let just saw a decent human
being a Bloomberg or something else will
come back and decency will be
appreciated because I don't think this
outrage thing can run forever it's too
it's too mentally exhausting it's - it's
physically there's a decent man I've
known for years is Joe Biden nobody
dislikes some wonderful father that
there was a great senator great vice
president if he were a little younger
can you imagine he'd be what 82 or
something because she can't dislike them
you want to be VP no I couldn't take the
cut and pay alright let's let's finish
up with some some big picture it's a big
picture stuff looking back is there
anything you would have done differently
career when I got married as much I
would have gone national sooner I had
the talent but I was a big fish in a
small pond in Miami and I like that I'd
radio television column and the Miami
Herald
you know everybody knew me in Miami I
never sent a tape to New York right I
should have I would have liked to gone
national sooner just just to have more
success earlier kids appeal more people
of course I had something I knew I was
good I know I was good at what I did and
I I didn't really get well-known till my
fifties and I think it could happen in
the 30s I'm not any better than I was in
the thirties I'm not better today than
our
when I was in my late 20s I was also I
always was curious I always let my eagle
at the door or was there short questions
always got really interested in the
guests that never changed sometimes
someone will play me a tape that they
had for 30 years ago stole me yeah I'm
still they're still asking questions I
think the first time I interviewed you I
asked you something about the ego
component relative to to interviewing
and your answer I loved it and I've
really tried to incorporate it in what I
do which is you said the show was called
Larry King tonight my ego is already
stroked I'll be there tomorrow
my motto it's a good model David could
be your model could be anybody's model
if Donald Trump had this model we would
be a better country this is my model I
never learned anything when I was
talking think about it I never learned
anything when I was talking now I may
impart things to people
I may be some knowledge but I haven't
learnt anything when I'm talking it
feels like a privilege in a way right
when you have somebody great across from
you and you get jam with this I'm
telling you this hour of my life is a
privilege oh to be on a Rubin report to
be part of what by the way senses a
report do I get a grade you will be
graded at the Oh trust me the YouTube
commenters they're gonna get you to
comment so they're gonna see I don't
have the wool with all how-do-you-do
must be Larry King that is the last
thing I want to impart on you all right
final question here we go what's it all
about I've asked you this I've asked you
some version of this many times a day
what's it all about my friend what's it
all about and what does it all mean what
does it mean a hundred years from today
who's gonna care john lowenstein once
hit a grand slam home run for the
Orioles to beat the Yankees and then
with crowd went crazy
someone said John how does it feel and
he said a hundred million Chinese don't
give a damn what does it all mean
answer is I don't know all right my
friend well despite the fact that you
did not wear suspenders today I did not
I want them to be totally casual with
you this true this is what it's about
what I what we just did for the last
hour thank you baby thank you my
pleasure and thank you for the milkshake
all right you guys can check out Larry
on aura TV and follow them on Twitter at
Kings things
[Music]